i want to live in a time when china is
not rising up so much and we're better
off in the u.s economy what should i do
should i lobby my members of congress
not to print so much money what should i
do about it if anything
um well again it's or the cycles are
science you can't do that if i think if
if we go back and we look at history
there are three main things that you can
do okay
uh first
uh as a society individually and then
collectively
um how do you earn more money than you
spend and how do you build a balance
sheet that has more assets than
liabilities that's a healthy and so
keeping that in mind the second is
internal conflict or cooperation can you
have internal cooperation because you
realize what the consequences are so i
think that in the 2024 elections there
is a reasonable chance that neither
party will accept losing the elections
and that is something that means that
democracy or a type of civil war of
sorts could develop in a way this is
realistic i'm not being
exaggerated by that and when one looks
at those types of things there is a
worry that one should have about the
divisiveness and what it means for each
other and the same is true
internationally so basically if you
anybody who's gone into wars this
through history
um the people who are the most convinced
that that's the thing to do all
regretted going into wars because of
what wars are like